you cannot both hate someone and
understand them at the same time if I am
very angry with someone it's become a
check for me where I'm like oh I must
not understand something like there's
something about them or something about
their experience that has made me not
understand why they do what they do most
people if you were born with the same
genetics and live the same life as that
person you would see the world the same
way as they do what if our Viewpoint of
the world is something that someone else
hates entirely in their mind we are
wrong hard to even really get into that
and like empathize with someone else's
point of view to that degree but me
going through that process has actually
been one that I've repeated did multiple
times in my life when I was extremely
angry with someone